er verfügt über 200.000 mal mehr
leistungen als die neuesten laptops auf
dem markt und braucht so viel strom wie
rund 12.000 haushalte und das allein für
die kühlung der neue supercomputer namen
zu sammeln
er wird gerade im amerikanischen
tennessee gebaut und wird wohl im
kommenden jahr als mächtigster computer
überhaupt an den start gehen wie es
damit funktioniert was er alles kann und
welche bedeutenden fragen der
wissenschaft er vielleicht schon bald
beantworten wird jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
forschungsteams weltweit müssen
heutzutage mit immer mehr daten klar
kommen und sie vernünftig auswerten um
den großen rätsel der wissenschaft auf
die spur zu kommen big data heißt das
schlagwort herkömmliche labor pc sind
gar nicht in der lage die riesigen
mengen an daten zu verarbeiten die
beispielsweise den klimawandel
beschreiben auch für die entwicklung von
medikamenten oder bei der
materialforschung müssen komplizierte
und vor allem gigantisch große
datenmengen ausgewertet werden um
voranzukommen im nächsten jahr wird dies
wahrscheinlich wieder ein stückchen
einfacher denn dann soll der
supercomputer summit an den start gehen
der derzeit am bridge national
laboratory in tennessee gebaut wird dann
wird er wohl auch sein vorgänger titan
ablösen der lange als der krasseste
supercomputer überhaupt galt doch damit
wird dafür sorgen dass titan ausgedient
hat und wohl nur noch ein jahr weiter
laufen soll
manche bezeichnen ihn schon jetzt als
alte maschine zu recht denn summits
rechenleistung wird wohl mindestens fünf
bis zehn mal so hoch sein
es ist einfach der reine wahnsinn was
damit können wird pro sekunde wird er
nach plan des forschungsteams rund 200
milliarden operationen durchführen
können ermöglicht wird das durch sein
innenleben gerade würde mit sogenannten
knoten ausgestattet insgesamt 4.600
davon wird damit am ende besitzen und
jeder einzelne davon kann rund 40
teraflops leisten klubs steht für
floating point operations per second
also auf deutsch gleitkommaoperationen
pro sekunde wobei gleitkomma die art der
zahlen darstellung bei computern
bezeichnet flops geben also grob gesagt
an wie viele berechnungen ein rechner
pro sekunde schafft dadurch dass den
supercomputer
das haben wir zahllose prozessoren
kombiniert werden erreichen sie ein
gesamter rechenleistung sogar petaflops
also das milliardenfache dafür steht
peter an flops damit soll 200 peta flops
schaffen um diese rechenleistung zu
erzielen braucht sah mit unfassbar viel
energie zudem produziert er bei seiner
rechnerei eine unvorstellbare hitze 20
megawatt sind notwendig um den
supercomputer und seine umgebung vor
überhitzung zu schützen
das ist etwa so viel energie wie etwa
12.000 häuser an strom verbrauchen
denn jeder der 4600 noten von summit
muss einzeln gekühlt werden
ein riesige herausforderung die lösung
dafür eine sogenannte kalte platten
technologie in jedem einzelnen knoten
bei der kühlendes wasser durch die ober
platte geleitet wird dadurch werden
tatsächlich etwa 70 prozent der hitze
absorbiert das wasser ist übrigens 21
grad warm wenn wäre das eiskalt würde
sich zu bilden der sammet gefährlich
werden könnte 30.000 liter wasser pro
minute müssen deswegen fließen um diese
kühlleistung zu garantieren diese
kühltechnik ist für solche supercomputer
innovativ der supercomm für titan wird
noch durch ein gefriert system gekühlt
andere systeme seine art durch einen
bart ausfüllen bis nächsten monat laufen
wohl noch die letzten installationen
dann wird sammelt noch eine zeitlang auf
schwachstellen getestet bis er dann als
wahrscheinlich mächtigster computer
überhaupt seinen dienst aufnehmen wird
hier bei pixum erfahrt ihr natürlich
wenn dort neue bahnbrechende
erkenntnisse gewonnen werden wenn er
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit ist das
universum ein supercomputer
das wäre dann tatsächlich der ultimative
supercomputer wie forscherinnen und
forscher auf diese idee gekommen sind
einfach draufklicken und am ende seid
ihr schlauer und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran